Now I heard that you were meaning to get
in touch with me but then I heard you
were dead
and I also heard that you were a king and
various other things but the fact is
sort people fear now I got the
Now I got the information that I needed now I have to
break your neck it's just the way it is
I'm not I'm just a messenger.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie! This is going to
be my new Marvel phase 4 video you
probably heard the news in the past week
Marvel has plans to bring a version of
Thanos back in future movies so we'll
break it down there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs it's not quite what you
would expect but Josh Brolin did say
many times he would love to come back
for more Thanos after Avengers endgame
so I'll explain what this means in the
projects that they're talking about
bringing him back for if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos will do a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know where
you want to see Thanos comeback in
future movies so just starting with
number 5 recently you probably saw the
report about Thanos coming back most
people assume that means he's coming
back to life but that's not exactly
what's happening it's not a brand new
idea either
right after avengers endgame the Russos
and the writers of infinity war and
endgame said that they wouldn't bring
these versions of Thanos back to life
the ones that died during endgame
remember there were two versions of
Thanos that the Avengers killed there
was the original version of Fanus after
he snapped half the universe with the
Infinity Gauntlet on his new garden
planet then he atomized the Infinity
stones to prevent anyone from using them
again and then Thor went for the head
and that was the end of that version of
Thanos then the second version of Thanos
was the one from 2014 the time traveled
into the future to this battlefield
Ironman snapped him away along with his
army from 2014
using the Nano Infinity Gauntlet
so now you're probably starting to
understand the logic of how Thanos is
actually coming back in a movie
eventually it'll be a Thanos from the
past before infinity war an endgame
doing movies said in the past not a
brand new idea that's exactly what
they're doing with the Black Widow movie
Black Widow before she died in Avengers
endgame so number four the first project
being talked about at Marvel is bringing
him back during the Eternals movies as a
younger version of Thanos before he got
super thick inserted his quest to
balance the universe and it wouldn't be
the first eternals movie he's not going to
show up during that but during the
sequels this is what teenage Thanos
looks like on the planet Titan with his
family they created this when they were
developing infinity war for some scenes
that never saw the light of day the
reason they use it in an eternal movie
sequel is because Thanos is an eternal
technically he's a deviant but they're
almost the same thing demons are just
what they call the Eternals who are born
with genetic abnormalities that make
them look different sometimes they look
like monsters sometimes it's just as
simple as Stannis having different color
skin than the rest of his biological
family this is what his family looks
like in the comics the concept art that
they created for Avengers infinity war
when they were constructing the portions
of the movie on Titan for the big Titan
battle the writers said that they wrote
a whole bunch of extra backstory as part
of Thanos flashback scene with the
reality stone so when he's standing here
telling dr. strange about what happened
to Titan and how his quest to balance
the universe quote-unquote started in
the theatrical cut he just waves his
hand and they show you some backgrounds
of pre destruction Titan based on what
the writer said in the concept art and
the longer version of this it sounded
like they would have just shown you
young Thanos scenes with his whole
family in a couple of flashback scenes
while the old Thanos is narrating so
number three Thanos his father's name is
a large as Red Skull told us on Boromir
he was actually a full-blown eternal
born on planet Earth so technically
Thanos actually shares a lot of genetic
similarities with all the Avengers let
that sink in for a minute
eternals are basically just humans that
have been genetically altered by the
Celestials and most of humanity just
descends from all those original
Eternals they don't really address that
during Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgame but that's because they were
doing the Eternals movies they'll get
into a lot of that back story when we
see that movie Thanos his father
eventually left earth after a couple of
civil wars with the Eternals and the
deviance and eventually helped colonize
the planet Titan started the family with
a nurses mother then a little while
later Thanos was born with the genetic
abnormality marking him as a deviant the
Thanos comic book gets into the
circumstances of his birth way more the
bad omens his mother being driven kind
of mad and they adhere a little more
closely to his previous comic book Canon
with the cosmic entity death in his
relationship they didn't really do that
with the MCU movies so I'm not expecting
a ton of that in the movies though in
the Eternals sequels the idea would be
they just show some sort of young fan
OHS being born in the Eternals
colonizing Titan to tie everything back
to the infinity saga of movies which
Marvel movies allowed to do big payoffs
years later that helped connect the new
movies to the older movies there's also
a whole history of young fan OHS flying
around the galaxy with his crew before
he knew about the Infinity stones
balancing the planets one by one we got
a little bit of that during infinity war
this is Thanos before he acquired any of
the Infinity stones when he took the
Morris planet perfectly bound in after
endgame I did get a lot of questions
about the Infinity stones and Thanos if
he destroyed the Infinity stones in
present day then how does time continue
to operate in the normal way because of
that whole explainer that the ancient
one gave to the Hulk the Infinity stones
create the normal flow of time as we
experience it the way the writers of the
movie in the Russos explained it is that
the stones themselves still exists in
atomized form so they're still within
the universe it's just the form that
they exist in now is unusable by other
people
number two the other big project that
they're talking about bringing stano's
back for is to set up a nova movie
origin story for richard ryder nova
there was an entire deleted subplot from
Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgame featuring an origin story in a
story arc for the Nova character
originally the writer said what happened
was is that during Infinity Ward the
movie actually opened with a huge action
scene of Thanos destroying Xander and
the Nova Corps using the Power Stone
Richard Reiter was going to be the sole
survivor and that was going to be the
beginning of his origins
we as the Nova character from the comics
they haven't really explained the Nova
force in the movies yet the cosmic nova
energy but that's the power that the
nova corps wields they use it to power
all their weapons and their never-ending
wars with the Kree and the Skrulls but
after the Nova Corps was destroyed by
Thanos ons and are all the power goes to
Richard Ryder and he gets his cosmic
level power up and it was going to be a
similar revenge arc like Thor during
infinity war when he goes to get
Stormbreaker Nova himself wouldn't have
had a ton of scenes during infinity war
after that but he would have come back
at the end of Avengers endgame during
the big final battle so when you see
everyone portaling in here he would have
come flying in during the tenth inning
and kicked a bunch of ass remember the
joke that the Russos had about the
deleted scene quote-unquote from
avengers endgame with nova macho man
Russo brothers how do you guys not have
any Nova Corp member in a fight against
Thanos love the movie but just boggles
my mind didn't even have to be Richard
Ryder I look closely at that scene again
there and you will see there are
thousands of people yeah you will see
Richard Ryder in the background of a
shot Easter Egg even though that clip is
them mostly joking because there is no
Nova in the theatrical cut of Avengers
endgame no matter how much you zoom and
enhance you won't find him there the
whole idea was is that there was a
version of the movie during the
development process where Nova was in
this scene so that's mostly the Russo is
just joking about that presumably after
this version of the movie where he did
show up he would have just gone on to
another space based movie in the future
or wherever Marvel wanted to use him
next Kevin Feige has said in the past
that they discussed doing a Nova movie
in more space based movies but there's
no official date on that yet part of the
reason for that spider-man far from home
post-credits scene though with Nick Fury
is to let you know that the Avengers
level threats will be coming from outer
space soon so they're just confirming
more space-based movies in Marvel phase
4 Marvel phase 5 and beyond that the
number one the other movies and stories
I'd love to see them bring Thanos back
for or actually a supernatural story now
that Doctor Strange multiverse of
madness is getting super crazy with
alternate realities and darker weirder
characters are coming like Moon Knight
blade Ghost Rider
Mephisto I'd love to see them bring a
version of Thanos back as dead Thanos in
the MCU
version of hell just being tormented by
Mephisto in Chains not a really big
scene just him in the background being
tormented because he's still dead or
they do a really weird Marvel what-if
episode featuring the cosmic version of
Ghost Rider in a subplot from the more
recent comics with tiny baby Thanos if
you haven't read any of those recent
comics Donnie Cates cosmic ghost riders
probably one of my new favorite versions
of the character he's a distant future
version of the Frank Castle Punisher
who's bonded with the spirit of
vengeance remember the scene from
avengers endgame where war machine is
like why don't we just time travel into
the past and kill tiny baby Thanos
wouldn't that solve all our problems
well in this version of the Ghost Rider
story Frank Castle Ghost Rider actually
tries to do that as you would expect it
goes terribly and he can't bring himself
to kill a child Frank Castle cosmic
Ghost Rider decides he's going to raise
danos to be good instead of being evil
but it goes so wrong because he's such a
terrible father that he winds up raising
phantos to accidentally take the mantle
of the Punisher and he becomes Punisher
Thanos an even worse version of Thanos
than they had before so that's a little
bit more of a comedic spin which is
why I say it pipework better is an
animated Marvel what-if episode but let
me know in the comments what version of
Thanos do you want to see come back in a
new movie
congratulations last Panda you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details every one click here for my
brand new venom 2 spider-man 3 and
Morbius video and click here to learn
all about the new Batman TV show that
HBO is going to be doing soon thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!